the Iman Ali mosque long known as the
Blue Mosque home to the Islamic Center
of Hamburg or izh on Thursday was one of
54 locations searched by German police
involving hundreds of officers in seven
states but the isz was the focal
point the suspicions against the Islamic
Center Hamburg are serious it's long
been under observation by the federal
office for the protection of the
Constitution and is also classified as
IST our security authorities will of
course now carefully evaluate the
confiscated material the searches around
Germany were all at Islamic centers
connected with the izh as here in Berlin
the German authorities say groups
influenced by the izh are often
associated with an anti-israeli and an
anti-semitic attitude officers believe
the izh is linked to Hezbollah an
organization that was banned in Germany
and officially labeled terrorist in
April
2020 to many in the intelligence and
security framework here that means links
with Iran here at the interior Ministry
Nancy faser has stressed that this
investigation is not directed against a
country or a religion but she's also
said that at a time when many Jews feel
particularly threatened Germany does not
tolerate anti-israeli or anti-semitic
incitement Dominic Kain Al jazer
Berlin make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer